anyone who becomes convinced of the
truth of Islam may accept the faith of
his or her own volition the unbelievers
are required to pay jizya in return for
the security provided to them as the
dimness zoombies the protected people up
in Islamic state
[Music]
nice
so you want the children out of here
[Music]
my changes
and adult again self-righteous their
shoes
music - a popular early dinner
you are
the destruction
totalitarians
[Music]
what are they
are you covering your faces yeah thanks
you know I appreciate your saying but
really I hope they're close what my
stand for here that's the whole idea is
to have a discussion the idea of the
university as a matter fact is to engage
in the discussions of ideas and ideas
are supposed to be accepted or rejected
on their merits no no please no
justification for leaving a major
university they have no understanding
about university ought to be about your
respect for free discourse and freaking
query and they are propagandizing the
smear artists who have defamed me and
they have not it's not personal I never
met them it's not about me they defamed
me because they don't like the ideas
that I represent but the idea that they
would say to students oh this is hate
speech and all that without letting
students think for themselves and
evaluate for themselves without
encouraging the students to come here
and to confront ideas that they might
not have heard before and my point
unwelcome that is the height of academic
irresponsibility and a betrayal of what
a university really is
[Applause]